[Music]
so a texas death row inmate has asked
for an execution delay
because he would like
to donate his kidney what a nice dude
he's like wait don't kill me wait wait
did he ask like like right when he's in
the chair
he's like wait who wants these kidneys
fire sale right fire sale wait so why do
they need to delay it they just go okay
got it no because they can't poison him
right they gotta harvest that kill him
dude gotta get it out
he's gonna wake up in a bathtub full of
ice first what's the delay on that
though [ __ ] in a week
um
so so this was just recently right his
lawyer's appeal to delay the execution
by a month
so that he can be considered a living
donor to someone who's an urgent any of
a kidney transplant so he they don't
even know who yet that's pretty fire yo
i'm gonna do this so they don't have
already a person who's like
like running through slow motion you
know coming into the prison like this is
the exact really really rare kidney
that's needed and that's the one
recipient it's just more like the
concept of first of all i'm glad you're
aware of the scientific process
they always run slow motion in the
movies that's with the manila folder
here's the file yeah yeah how come i'm
imagining something else where
he has he gets okay for the one month
delay and there's a guy running slow
motion like hey we have one month to
break boss out um oh yeah
i'm he knows the science too that's what
i'm thinking
he has he goes okay cool now i got 30
days of strategizing the [ __ ] out of
here oh yeah and then there's the guy
who's sitting on a plane he's got a
little tupperware container oh it's
empty right now he's going like that and
he's looking at his watch yeah the heart
jumping around the desk
later like
airplane jokes that's a classic airplane
best movie uh ever ever so no um
so some people
are questioning whether or not he is
just trying to spare himself a little
bit of time yeah no [ __ ] [ __ ]
i don't think so though he's still got
to pay up either way
he's still got to get rid of that as
long as he still dies i guess right
right i would [ __ ] give a kidney i
give everything away for another month
you know what i mean if i'm gonna die
anyway i'm not gonna use it what are you
doing a month what are you gonna do a
month behind bars though yeah which
would be a month probably in like the
hospital which is like nicer than the
normal jail
or or maybe but it's all coming to one
maybe there's got to be one ounce of
like uh redemption for himself to think
like if i donated my kiddie maybe i'm
doing something for some
somebody else's life that might be
positive before i die for whatever
problems
at the same time i can get my homies to
break me out in 30 days he says that's
not why he's doing it yeah right what's
he doing which one the breaking out or
the
you guys are you guys are a bunch of
[ __ ] judgers dude
what's this full in
jail anyways folks yeah yeah that's a
good question so
stealing organs
stealing kidneys organs he's the biggest
organ theme in the world he knows the
system it's time to give back he's in
jail
uh
unfortunately for kidnapping sexual
assault and the murder of a teenager in
2001. jesus see this [ __ ] trying
to get out who's trying to take his
kidney
is there an emotional like attachment to
a kidney would you would you want to
take that like if you're if you needed a
kidney and then you your [ __ ] organ
daughter okay i've been on the list for
so long the kidney left that matches is
hitler's
only killing
fine only one if i have hitler's kidney
yeah i don't give a [ __ ] if it's the
only one left but if i got a choice at a
time you start hating jewish people
after you took what if you start goose
stepping around what if he [ __ ]
his [ __ ] blood comes into your system
and you become him slowly just like you
start growing a mustache
oh dang honestly
that's like not my fault but that would
be like something of a study right or
it's a good movie being a little more
fair maybe i start to become pretty
decent in military strategy
how would you find that out so you get
the pros too maybe he's gonna be an
author a failed artist
a really popular a vegetarian i'm like i
have a really good idea for a military
strategy that will eventually have me
killing myself because of my oh [ __ ] i
[ __ ] up
i did too much the difference is you
don't kill yourself at the end that's
all well do some people say that didn't
happen anyway because he escaped
argentina still alive dude
yeah
and he's chilling with tupac he worked
in nasa i heard he got into
onto a boat a submarine that's what they
say anyone tell me what he looks like
without the [ __ ] mustache because i
think if you shave that photoshop it's
it's done he looks like charlie chaplin
without them yeah i'll be like who is he
or what if he used charlie chaplin
because he had the mustache and just put
a hat on you know he still got the
haircut though the little [ __ ] this
little thing they say hitler was really
good at physical comedy
he was a really funny dude he was good
at physical comedy i bet he's really he
is very charming he had a sense of humor
he's a comedian
when i see him on [ __ ] giving a
speech and he just [ __ ] nine nine
nine i'm like this guy's a [ __ ]
charmer dude yeah nick dunn
adolf hitler was really charming give
him a chance that's what it is adolf
hitler give him a chance
like i don't get it i don't get it why
everyone cares so much
get over it dude it's history unless he
was juggling yeah
if he found that that he was a juggler
that'll be the problem he's going to
[ __ ] punch him in this [ __ ] i was
in vienna where um he did his [ __ ]
big speech right uh fire
it was yeah it was so fire it was like
fire yeah
you had to be there dude no but i was
right there right and i swear to god i
felt this [ __ ] weird feeling of just
like
dictator energy oh wow i didn't know you
were going to say tater after that and
then joe's like this guy was kind of
right
that's a good point it's like the
bermuda triangle of racism i think he's
done that he's just like
maybe he had a point he had a point for
someone maybe jewish people no no don't
it was crazy though that whole [ __ ]
area but the way that they designed that
[ __ ] area with the whole street it's
like they put hell of thought into
having this presence right so if you
just stand by the steps
it makes you feel like you're just god
so it's like when you're standing in the
steps and you're just you have this
[ __ ] building with an eagle and then
the [ __ ] this there's this like
ancient ass like king with like a
[ __ ] stallion just [ __ ] pharaoh
yeah hell yeah and there's this big
street and then you can just imagine all
the people looking at you right there
you're like oh god no wonder this guy
thought he was like
start looking up thinking about world
domination right and then joe malio was
born that day
that was the day dude i was there though
i was in germany and same kind of thing
like you could say i was there world war
ii yeah no same kind of [ __ ] right where
you're walking those streets and it's
just this eerie thing and i can't tell
if it's because like when i was a kid i
remember seeing all that in the history
books and like i'm literally standing on
the same thing that's a trip like that's
a trip i bet for sure
like mentally with some [ __ ] i bet
there's some energy there there's some
weird [ __ ] energy there but also
dictator energy yeah you're probably
just cold it's full of [ __ ] dead at
winter oh just like oh [ __ ] there's
something this history here chilling my
bones nicki we're fighting we're on
[ __ ]
we're
traveling way too much for a limited
amount of time we were going to every
country in europe just about like but we
were only there for two days
so it was like what mostly not really
getting to enjoy it we were just fine we
were trying to hit all those countries
in two days yeah
wow so you're like in a in a country for
like three hours and you go to a next
one yeah
basically i mean not really but
basically it was like dude we were there
for a day max and then we're already
getting like going to the airport
getting on a plane oh you're flying
everywhere
the train you guys should have done the
trip we did the train too but yeah it
mostly flew but it was a [ __ ] dude bh
and a half like when we got to amsterdam
we're like oh my god can we just [ __ ]
please stay here yeah
you guys should have taken a giant like
[ __ ] joint went oh yeah i'm gonna
relax now [ __ ] a hooker i would but we
don't smoke marijuana oh that's [ __ ]
hookers that's true
because that's exactly what i did it was
amazing you don't have to smoke it you
could just eat a space cake what's a
space cake oh edible yeah
first time i ever had space cake my life
was an amsterdam i ate a cupcake and
then i went back to my hostel and i lied
there and it was like for four hours i
was thinking see i don't like it did you
like that no i don't like it
no you should eat one i didn't hate it
it was just more like i felt the sinking
feeling by the time i got up and the
sinking feeling was done i looked in my
car and i was like
it's been four hours
being separated from my brain is too
weird for me too you can't handle it you
want to be able to do stuff while you're
on vacation yes exactly i want to enjoy
[ __ ] i got really high in amsterdam and
then um i i somehow find myself on a bed
and this hooker was sucking my dick and
i and i swear to god i turned into a
boba inside of a hole i was a i was
inside of this boba cup and then my dick
was the straw she was sucking the bulba
out of it and i was like no that's my
soul
and she was sucking out on my dick
that's what happened
give me and then you opened a boba shop
and now like yeah
and that's great
can we have your mom on the show and do
hot seat oh yeah for sure okay cool we
can talk about all that [ __ ] can we play
clips i'll be like mom come from japan
and we'll [ __ ] ask you all these
questions i just want to sit down with
maybe ryan for a day and we'll pull our
favorite joe moment clips and then we'll
have joe's mom here and we'll just play
but we silhouette joe out just joe so
it's like who do you think question mark
bart or joe
she watches everything
she watches all of our vlogs she follows
she probably follows all you guys on
instagram she watches it doesn't follow
me
like yeah
wherever i tag yeah and then well she i
think she's like it's helping me
practice english that's cute but i'm i
scold her and say [ __ ] you've been in
america longer than me how the [ __ ] do
you is your english like still bad i
learned cream pie from you
rusty
[Laughter]
nikki's grandma
is like filipino grandma all the way
right she came here from there but she's
lived in america longer than i've been
[ __ ] alive
and she can't speak
at all barely at all just make it work
dude it's hilarious it's the best my
dad's like that too my mom asked me what
calm was and i was like oh that's just
semen and i told her the the scientific
uh explanation in japanese and she goes
oh i'm sorry i asked
real quick though what's the uh can you
what's the scientific explanation in
japanese yeah
yeah that's it that's common and what
does she mean firm
oh just like spread
yeah
i meant i thought i meant like juice of
the testicle or something i don't know
maybe i'm wrong but that's that's what i
blossoming of the penile
you know what could you you know kuji
means right could you
whale [ __ ] yeah don't forget it
[Music]
you